Okay. So before I start, I just want to
ask you um what proof do you expect for
Jesus be being a Muslim? For Jesus being
a Muslim, you know, historical
information on his life, you know, um
showing me what he truly believed, how
he practiced his religion, and that what
he believed and how he practiced his
religion lines up with Islam. Do you
accept um proof from the Bible? Yeah,
100%. Okay. According to you, what what
was his religion? According to you, he
was a Jew. He believed in Yahweh. Um, he
believed in, you know, following the law
of Moses, you know, he believed that he
is the son of, you know, the son of God
who salvation is only through. So, a Jew
but not the Judaism of today. Not
Judaism of today. No. Judaism of today
is radically different from Judaism in
his time. Okay. Did Judaism of his time
and the time of Moses change throughout
time or did was it always? Yeah, you
have it changing throughout time. You
have different generations of Judaism.
Yeah. But every single Israelite was um
on the same religion as Jesus but a bit
different. I wouldn't say every single
Israelite because when the Messiah Yes.
Yeah. You know when the Messiah came
they rejected him. They followed they
changed the religion of God. religion of
men. Yeah. So, but yeah, for the most
part. Yeah. So, they were they were
blind when he came. 100%. Okay. And do
you believe that Jesus is likened to the
whole nation of Israel? That Jesus is
likened to the nation of Israel? Yeah.
For example, in Matthew 2:15. Yeah.
Okay. Um
um do you uh know how many times um does
um the word equivalent in Hebrew for
Muslim appear in the Old Testament? If
you believe it, I Yeah, I wouldn't say
it's an equivalent of the word Muslim. I
would say that it is relat there is a
word that is related to the word because
they share the same root. So you have
the word in Isaiah 42:1 19. Yes.
Exactly. And if you if you can open it.
Yeah. Yeah. So that that word is not
Muslim. It's not the equivalent. It's it
has the same word. You can just open the
Bible commentary in Bible Bible hub the
Christian combination say. Okay. Yeah.
Let's go ahead and and check it out. All
right. Isaiah chapter 42 verse 19. And
is Isaiah 42 about Jesus uh their
servant or somebody else? The first half
the first half is about Jesus the
servant. Okay. Um, when you get to
verses 18 and down, that's talking about
the nation of Israel. Not Jes not Jesus
anymore.
Because you see the difference, right?
The difference the servant in the
beginning is the savior. He's perfect,
right? The servant I know because I went
I went through the whole chapter. Good.
So, so then so then you agree that
there's two servants being described,
right? Yes. Exactly. Two servants. The
first one isn't blind and the the second
from 18 all the way to the end is the
blind servant. Yes. Perfect, man.
Perfect. Perfect. All right. That's
good. That's good. That helps. It helps
that you actually bring Yes. The for
example, I'm about to I'm about I'm
about to show it. I'm about to Oh, you
want a commentary or do you want the
lexicon? You can go both. You can go to
the commentary first and then All right.
So, which commentary do you want? You
want elots? Yes. Yes. Okay. All right.
Just read. I see that is perfect in the
second part if you can read it. Uh, I'll
show it on the screen. You will see
until then. And if you can put it on the
screen so people can see it. I will
host. Just be patient with me. Thank
you. All right, ladies and gents. So,
over on the side, let me actually put
the Bible over here on the side here.
All right. So, on the right, we got
Isaiah 42:19.
If you can commentary, this part right
here. Right. As he that is perfect. All
right. Strictly speaking, the devote the
devoted or surrendered one. The Hebrew
mashulam is interesting as connected
with the modern Muslim and Islam. The
man resigned to the will of God. The
frequent use of this or a cognate form
as a proper name after the exile. It
gives a few verses may either assumption
as to the date of uh second Isaiah be
connected with it by some link of
causation. Other meanings given to it
have been perfect as in the authorized
version confident or recompensed or uh
meritorious. So what it is is that
there's a connection between the word
musham and the word Muslim in the
Arabic. Yes, there is because the root
word of mul is because they have the
same root word the same root word and
salam is in Arabic and the root for
Muslim is also salam. You can we can we
can agree because this is important. We
can agree though although there is a
connection between the words they're not
the same word right of course because
they're different languages but they are
basically different languages with
different meanings too. You can go to
the
lexicon I mean it says the surrender
one.
Well that's that's what that's what the
Muslim word means. So exactly. Yeah. So
what what Elott says he literally says
here that as he that is perfect. So he
shows that it means perfect and he gives
the interpretation strictly speaking the
devoted or surrendered one. Right? So
when we go to the lexicon you can go to
the lexicon. Yes. How do I do this? You
go go to the right on the second uh the
hold on I need to how do I just do this
on the comments? You you can I believe
go to the right. There we go. Yes. On
the 19. This isn't the lexicon. Well,
this is the interlinear. I know,
brother. I'm I'm getting there. Just
give me a second. Here it is. So, when
we open the lexicon, we see the
definition of the word to be complete,
to be sound, to make amends, to finish,
to repay, or to reward. Right? That's
the meaning of the word. It does not
have the same meaning as Muslim. Well,
okay. Can you please go down on the same
lexicon to the brown Greeks? I believe
this is a different lexicon. Go. You
see, stop on the Arabic. You see the
root word. I know. I know. A Muslim
debater. Trust me, I've I've ran through
this before. So, okay. Now, now the the
the confusion that a lot of you guys
bring is you guys think that because
they're have they have the same root
that they mean the same thing. They
don't as we just saw. These are two
different like this is the Hebrew. The
Hebrew word means to be complete and
sound, right? That's in the Hebrew,
right? In the Arabic. This is these
aren't the only meanings. Correct. These
are their own meanings. So they have
different meanings even though they have
the same root. When we go to the Arabic
we see it gives it in the Arabic right
here. Uhhuh. We see it the word and its
root resign or submit oneself especially
to God when participle Muslim and Islam
proper submission to God. There you go.
Yeah. So do you do you do you Yeah, I
hear you Muslim debater. Do you see that
these are two different words with two
different meanings in in their
perspective languages? You don't Okay.
Stop. Stop there for me. Muslim debator,
slow down. Right here, it gives a Hebrew
word and its meaning in the Hebrew,
right? Yes. Is that the same meaning in
the Arabic? But these aren't the only
meanings. That's what I asked. Is this
the same meaning in the Arabic here? No.
But these aren't the only meanings. All
right. So, it's not the same meaning in
the Arabic. We look at the meaning in
the Hebrew. We look at the meaning in
the Arabic, they mean two different
things. No, they don't. All right. So,
show me where it has the same exact
meaning. You're you're literally It says
here, especially to God when participle
Muslim and infinitive Islam properly
submission to God. Where does it say
that for the Hebrew word? It's
literally in the definition of the
Hebrew word. Yeah. Where do you see in
the definition of the Hebrew word? It
means to submit oneself or to resign
like a uh like a Muslim like the word
Muslim. Where does it say that? Here on
the screen. No. No. No. Where does it
say that for the Hebrew? Are you Are you
okay? No, for the Hebrew it doesn't say
here, but it's the equivalence in
Arabic. It doesn't use the equivalence.
The only thing that you have here,
Muslim debater, is you have two words
with similar roots with the same root.
That's what you have. But these are two
different words with two different
meanings. They share the same root in
two different languages though. Can we
agree with that? There the meanings are
both the same. The masham is a Muslim.
Okay, in Arabic if you can al All right,
let's get back to our subject here. Gave
the Muslim a chance. Gave the Munoon a
chance, man. Thanks for coming, big dog.
So, I hope for the rest of you Muslims
that are watching this, stop bringing up
Isaiah 42:19. It doesn't work. And
Christians, I hope that you're paying
attention because the Muslims are trying
to distort lexicons. They they don't
even know what they're looking at. They
don't know what they're reading. they
don't comprehend things or they do and
they just intentionally lie. Okay, stop
bringing up Isaiah 42:19 saying that the
Bible teaches that Jesus is a Muslim or
that Israel is a Muslim. No, it doesn't.
Just because two words have the same
root doesn't mean they're the same word
or have the same meaning as we just saw
and demonstrated. Same root in Arabic
and Hebrew, two different words with two
different meanings, but they're related.
They're connected. Yes. Not identical.
All right. So Christians, start crushing
them when they when they bring this up.
Start crushing them on these lives.